les quatre jours de procès ont été
éprouvants pour la famille de la victime
entre les détails d'une mort
particulièrement atroce c'est des
regrets à peine esquissés par l'accusé
l'affaire du meurtre de la Guinguette de
valers s'est conclut devant les assises
d'undre-et-loire aujourd'hui par la
condamnation de la fusée à 30 années de
prison Faustine lune le jugement a été
rendu Franck r vient d'être condamné à
30 ans de prison à sortie d'une peine de
sûreté de 20 ans à l'annonce de sa peine
c'est un soulagement pour la famille de
la victime Caroline D qui s'était
constituée partie civile faisant le
portrait d'un homme misogyne séducteur
insensible et d'un bourreau leur avocate
avait demandé une peine à la hauteur ses
chaussettes cette peine permet de penser
que Monsieur restera en maison d'arrêt
encore de nombreuses années et
qu'ensuite il sera interdit
d'Indre-et-Loire c'est quand même aussi
quelque chose qui qui rassure finalement
la famille on a pris vraiment en compte
la dangerosité de même au-delà des faits
qu'il a commis pour l'avenir en tout cas
c'est une condamnation plus élevée que
ce qu'avait requis l'avocate général
c'est-à-dire 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle mais a sorti d'une peine de
sûreté de 15 ans l'avocat de la défense
à lui insister sur le fait que ce
meurtre aurait été un acte isolé dans la
vie de Franck R et sur le syndrome
post-traumatique que ce dernier aurait
développé à la suite de son enfance en
Irak à leur en guerre il avait donc
demandé un verdict d'apaisement il est
certain que deux choses ont compté dans
ce dossier
la matérialité des faits en eux-mêmes
c'est vrai que le légiste a fait une
déposition qui est pesée et puis le
positionnement de l'accusé qui était
assez compliqué parce que c'était une
forme de déni c'est-à-dire que eu égard
la gravité des faits il a peiné à se
positionner par rapport au fait
il y a dix jours pour faire appel nous
allons y réfléchir avec mon client pour
rappel Franck r encourait la perpétuité
pour le meurtre de son ex-compagne à
coups de couteau en pleine après-midi à
la Guinguette de Valère en mars 2019
aujourd'hui il est resté égal à lui-même
comme tout au long du procès ne montrant
aucune empathie ni émotion dans sa
dernière prise de parole il a tout de
même adressé ses regrets à la famille et
à la société